[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today this is
in Richmond Virginia hi Dennis how are
you
Hi how are you uh so my name is Dennis
I'm 20 years old and my question is uh
is it crazy that I'm asking my mom for a
loan of eight thousand dollars now I
know the question sounds crazy because
it's not really a back story so can I
give you a brief backstory to go with it
sure
okay so I've been investing for about
two years now I started my freshman year
at college and I've been day trading for
about a year and a half
um my closest one of my closest friends
is a up-and-coming headphone manager so
I get a little bit of information from
him but I may be an investor
um about uh a year ago a year and a half
ago before I started really day trading
um I was only a referee that's my only
job I have because I'm in college so I
might make 500 in a weekend and I would
take uh probably about 300 out of that
500 and put it into Weeble to invest and
then just keep the other 200 to live off
and uh I'll just keep doing that and at
one point I asked my mom for three
thousand dollars because my um my father
had just paid all of our child all of my
child support at one time myself my year
um it was forty thousand dollars and I
was still trying to um you know
where's the money why do you need money
if you're day trading
why do I need money yeah did you lose
all your money
yes okay so that's right so you suck at
day trading and you want her to give you
money
not really because yeah really you lost
all your money you suck at it
well it was from my head because I've
also made all the money I didn't lose
where's the money how much money do you
have 30 000 how much money do you have
right now I own I don't have any money
in my brokerage account because I took I
took the rest of it out because I didn't
want to go any lower how much money have
you lost day trading
uh I lost about 15
000 in the a week yeah that's what made
me take my money out yeah but I've also
gained about 27
000 in less than a year yeah so okay let
me give you the numbers on this okay
78 percent
of day Traders
lose money net net
when the story is over eight out of ten
day Traders lose money
20 year old day traders who referee it's
the numbers approaching a hundred
percent
don't do this anymore
and your mother's right no she should
not give you money I would not give you
money
because you're going to lose it
even if you can see that the games are
there and if you check the company I
just told you 8 out of ten day Traders
lose money you're 20 freaking years old
and you referee games on the weekend
what makes you think you're better than
the others people
don't but okay you're going to lose
money then
why would you keep doing this
it gives me more money to invest at a
certain point my mom told me like her
mindset she nobody in the family invests
or does any of this stuff because they
don't want to do it like you told me
that I was stupid she's right no I was I
was first investing this is when she
told me that I was dumb for investment
for taking half my paycheck and just
investment stuff I I recently just found
out day trading and at first I didn't
day trade I was just hate so that's
where it had brought me up the amount of
money I bought from asdal calls and
bought some messed up you are playing a
game that guys that get paid millions of
dollars a year play and most of them
aren't good at it
I mean guys that run multi-billion
dollar mutual funds do what you do and
they still have questionable results
it takes them years and years and years
of training and experience to do this
not I've got a friend who was once
worked for a hedge fund and I'm 20 and I
Referee on the weekends you are you are
the recipe of a disaster sir please
don't do this anymore your mom is right
she smells a rat and it's you're gonna
hurt yourself son stop it I don't think
I'm gonna talk you out of it because I
think you're convinced yourself but dude
I mean
listen if eight out of 10 people that
walk down the street named a street get
attacked by a bear and killed
don't walk down a street
I mean this is it it's not I mean
why do I think what am I going to get a
bear suit I mean no I mean don't walk
down a street eight out of ten people
that walk down the street a bear kills
them son that's what I'm telling you you
know and Dennis I think please don't act
like you're different yeah and I think
the appeal right when you get rich quick
it is that's what I'm saying because I'm
like there's such a better formula to
handle your money long term
um and I think you have the you know you
have the capacity to do that to do it
the right way Dennis that lowers the
risk it's not going to be as exciting
and it's not going to be like boom boom
Oh my gosh this this and that it's not
going to bring that but it's going to
bring a level of stability and build a
really great financial life for yourself
by starting great habits I'm like just
slow down if you have debt Dennis pay it
off have some cash in the bank to save
and you're you you hustle you you're
looking for opportunity it's just your
momentum and your focus is just geared
in a way that's really risky and you're
not going to come out better on the
other end playing this versus doing in
the Commodities Market is almost as dumb
if not Dumber I did that
I have a finance degree I actually know
something about this stuff formally
academically studied it hello
um it was not I had a friend that was in
a hedge fund and a guy comes to me and
goes hey my buddy over here has been
doing gold trades and we're going to buy
some Futures on the gold trades at the
last 11 times that he has picked the
future date in our our purchase rate on
the thing and if we put in 5 000 bucks
we'll get 50 000 out the last he's 11
for 11 on his last five guess what I put
in 5 000 bucks in the 12th one he missed
which means you lose the whole five
thousand bucks you either get 50 or you
get nothing that's how this works so so
that was my gold investment because I'm
just as stupid and dumb I mean just as
everybody else I had to try it because
I'm smarter than everybody else let me
tell you Pride goes right before the
fall
once you think you find somebody's got
it all figured out and they got a system
yeah bullcrap okay the only system that
works is long-term investing in
long-term track record things where 80
90 of the people doing it make money not
worth 80 90 of the people lose money and
you think you're the freaking exception
this is how Vegas is operated everybody
thinks they're the exception and that's
why Bellagio has nicer Furniture in
their Lobby than you do because you paid
for it you people that thought you were
smarter than the house
that's why they have chaluy or whatever
that uh architecture it is crazy what is
the name of that famous sculpture that
does the lighting oh I know or whatever
Lighting in the lobby the blown glass
yeah probably probably
is that it sure the guys in the booth
are trying to help me with my hillbilly
but uh yeah it's like a million dollars
it's fantastic right over there right
over there right over where you check in
and guess who paid for that stupid
people that's who paid for that okay
people that thought they were going to
beat the house listen if you do it for
entertainment and you're out of debt all
amount of money and you choose it's not
entertaining to lose money
it's not entertaining to think you're
the exception of the rule I know
yeah you feel that way
I'm a 50 50 story oh God help us you and
Dennis go invest together this is what
you all need to do no it's just the
long-term play Dennis yeah don't don't
please and hey great for refereeing yeah
good for you no I'm just saying that
does not qualify you to be a day trader
I know because you can call out
five-year-old soccer games this doesn't
set you up to be a day trader it's not
it's not like the prerequisite to
winning it day trading
so um you know he does do hard work
thank you for that yes and thank you for
earning some extra money and so forth
but I think your mom is a precious lady
I love her she's got some sense mom
don't give Dennis any money
there you go
uh not for day trading that's right
sorry Dennis you didn't get what you
wanted here but you will always get the
truth because we love you and we don't
want to lie to you we want you to have a
good life and so we're always going to
tell you the truth even if it's fun